melania and ronnie seem to be two sides
of the same coin possibly even two
halves or two forms of the same bean
meaning they're the same person they
share a ton of common traits and i'd
like to go over those today in this
video i hope you guys like the new
format where i just sit in a pretty
looking spot and shoot the [ __ ] with you
guys because like all lore videos a ton
of this is speculation and shared
knowledge between the community as much
as i like reading your comments just
don't be a dick about it that's all i
can really say also i get some comments
about people getting upset about
spoilers in my videos my advice for this
is don't click on a lore video about a
game you haven't beaten yet it's not my
fault you're stupid so with all of that
out of the way let's talk about melna
and ronnie because i believe that they
are the same person just like queen
marca and radagon are the same person as
well and if you didn't know this you're
probably already really confused what
i'm about to discuss is my theory on why
ratagon in america can split into two
different beans while also being the
same person long ago queen marika and
her consort godfrey waged war against
the fire giants of the mountaintops
apparently like all wars that are waged
in this game it ends with no true victor
queen america realized that she could
not fully destroy the flame of the
giants so she instead cursed the last
giant to attend to the flame for all of
eternity the giant in turn cast a curse
of his own cursing marca with red hair
just like the fire giants to be rid of
this curse mark has split her body and
soul into two different entities using
the power of the elden ring this is why
we see queen marco rocking the hot
blonde locks and ratagon with the red
hair of the fire giant meaning that
they're two different sides of the same
coin but with their own individual
consciousness at this point in time
marika who again is ratagon i'm going to
hammer this fact into your brain until
you have two different beans and hair
colors but at this point in time marca
is still married to godfrey the first
elden lord she and godfrey had i think
three children named godwin morgott and
moog morgot and moog are twins and were
cursed as omens and were hidden away in
the depths below the capital i'm not
going to go too deep into that that can
be a video in and of itself apparently
i'm coming up with a lot of videos that
i can make within this video so that's
cool but marika is a very cunning queen
and likely sees a couple of interesting
opportunities with this situation one
she can now expand their kingdom's
territory by sending radagon to war with
karya and two she overthrows godry after
he lost his grace of the greater will
and exiles him from the lands between
making godfrey the first ever tarnished
during the war with karya ratagan
supposedly falls in love with the leader
of the qarian empire queen ranala now
there's some reason to believe that this
plan was devised by queen marica for
radagon to marry ranala instead of
another war where the outcome really
doesn't go well again this could be the
reason ratagan leaves ronaldo eventually
but that's speculation since ratagan
returned to marica after godfrey was
exiled so that he could become maraca's
consort and become the second elden lord
i cannot tell you how difficult this is
to explain since ratagan and marca are
the same person so i need you all to
just roll with it before this ratagon
and granola had three children named
reichard radon and ronnie all of these
children have their own stories that we
will discuss but we're going to focus on
ronnie's part for this one once marica
banished godfrey ratagan left ronald to
i guess go [ __ ] himself i i just imagine
ronaldo telling ratagan to go [ __ ]
himself after he leaves her and takes it
way too seriously like no wonder ronaldo
is heartbroken so why am i talking about
all of this i thought this video was
about melania and ronnie well kyle
that's right i'm talking to you kyle
someone out there must be named kyle i
promise it all fits so bear with me some
more please ratagan and marca go on to
have two more children melania and
michela however both of the children
were born with some problems melania
with the scarlet rot and michala with
the curse of forever being young i'm
going to go ahead and guess that they
were born with these curses because of
some weird inbred issues because ratagon
and marca are the same person but that's
all up to speculation so i'm explaining
all of this so that i can tell you that
in this world it's possible for all this
stuff to happen there can be two halves
of the same coin with different
consciousnesses this is why i believe
melano and ronnie are the same person
just with two different halves so let's
get into that as i hope we all know at
this point or you should go watch my
last lore video ronnie steals a fragment
of the rune of death from malakit and
used it to create the black knives who
killed not only godwin but also provided
her with the means to slay her own
empyrean flesh which removes her from
the influence of the two fingers this
was her goal from the start ronnie did
not want to be the successor of queen
marica so she split herself from it
completely see what i said there split
herself this is where i believe the two
sides of the same coin come back into
play for ronnie and melina they're the
same person but with two different
consciousness consciousnesses
consciousnesses i think that's right
let's look first at the little things we
notice that are similar about the two
ronnie has her right eye closed while
melano has her left eye closed ronnie
also has her twin at her side which
maybe it's just me thinking this but
looks an awful lot like melano with the
opposite side open like melna as well
when melania disappears after talking to
her she leaves a blue sparkle trail that
looks a lot like the same trail ronnie
leaves a lot of people speculate about
the tattoos i don't think they look too
similar but they both have tattoos so
that's gotta be something they're also
the only two npcs in the game that seem
to have a connection to torrent melano
obviously giving you the ring to call
upon torrent and ronnie giving us the
spirit calling bell that she says used
to belong to torrent's former master now
let's get a bit deeper with this ronnie
is the daughter of ranala while melina i
believe is the daughter of queen marika
we believe this to be true when she
tells us this there is something i'd
like to say
my purpose was given to me by my mother
but now
i act of my own volition
i have set my heart upon the world that
i would have
regardless
of my mother's designs
i won't allow anyone
to speak ill of that
not even you
she talks about her mother giving her
purpose inside of the erd tree which
would be queen marica still not entirely
sure but that's as good of a guess as i
can make it might even be possible that
melano is the embodiment of the
discarded great rune of ronnie which is
similar to how she discarded her
physical body at the top of the divine
tower of lurinia this could also explain
the burns on melania's hands since the
body of both ronnie and melana looks to
be burned i've even seen some more
speculations that they're the same
person from when melano opens her eyes
during the frenzied flame ending
lord or frenzied flame
i will seek you
as far as you may travel
to deliver you what is yours
that eye looks like the same tone and
the same hue as ronnie's it's hard to
say so discuss that down in the comments
please i'd love to see what you guys
think again just just don't be dicks
thank you because all of this is a lot
of information a lot of false
information is going to be spread around
as well just calmly discuss it i'd
appreciate it because there is a lot
more to discuss and we can save that for
another video thank you guys for
watching this one let me know if you
enjoyed the new format i'll see you all
in the next one have a great day guys
[Music]
you